Now, Python being Python actually gives lots of different ways of writing something this simple,
and some of them are very very distinct so here's a more distinct way of writing the same thing.
We can do is in one command sum up all the elements and divided by the length,
and we've now computed the same thing twice.
What do you suppose the running time is of the second statement here?
It's just one little arithmetic statement. It seems like it should be Θ(1), but it's not.
You have to keep in mind that this some command here is actually just shorthand for a loop like this.
It really is running overall the elements in the list internally.
Even though it looks like Θ(1), there's still a Θ(1) of the length of this list, your Θ(n).
This is one of the things that is different between the language like Python and say a language like C.
C basically doesn't allow you to hide running time in the individual statements.
All the C statements run pretty much constant time.
Whereas in Python, so that you can write more complicated programs in a nice distinct way,
they do give you the shortcuts, but you have to be really careful
that you know what the running time is with all the little primitive functions
before you try to actually measure the performance and predict how fast your algorithm is going to run.
This can really bite so you have to be careful.
The extremals of a list are the extreme values, the max and the mean,
which is a kind of cooler way to say it, the extremals, the X Games,
but it's actually an awful lot like mean.
What I would like you to do is actually modify the mean algorithm that we had
to actually compute the max of a list.